notre invité politique ce matin c'est
terrible alors bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous pour être
député et président de la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale et
soutient des manuels macron on est
ensemble pendant un peu plus de vingt
minutes pour des interviews en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par fabrice
veysseyre aux dons du groupe ebra
bonjour fabrice en jour organes
dangereuse et claire bonjour on commence
par l'ukraine évidemment verte le pire
est encore devant nous c'est ce qu'a dit
jean yves le drian vladimir poutine
poursuit son avancée il ya eu des
bombardements à kiev des qui ont été
entendus ce matin des explosions
entendues ce matin à kiev
l'armée russe qui n'exclut pas de
prendre le contrôle total des grandes
villes ukrainiennes est ce que ça veut
dire que les sanctions économiques
aujourd'hui elles ne servent à rien ah
non on peut pas dire ça du tout d'abord
beauce un drame absolu
chacun est bien conscient de tous les
français en sont conscients et des
gestes de solidarité locaux nationaux
qui sont évidemment formidable tout ça
est à nos portes enfin bref c'est une
horreur indicible
à tous points de vue je crois que les
les licences sur économique sont
aujourd'hui les seuls avec le discours
diplomatique avec la pression aussi
politique extrêmement forte du monde
entier sur le monsieur poutine sont
aujourd'hui les les voix qu'il faut
continuer à employer et ça ne se sa n'a
pas d'impact immédiat c'est pas comme
une bombe si vous l'avez qui explosent
comme ça d'un coup c'est évidemment des
choses plus lente à se mettre en place
elles vont monter en puissance
au porte monnaie c'est le nerf de la
guerre un toucher au porte monnaie je
porte monnaie personnelle de tous ces
oligarques qui profitent du système sur
le dos du peuple russe et puis de
l'autre
évidemment toucher au porte-monnaie de
l'état russe lui même et là tout le
débat sur l'énergie sur l'achat
d'énergie sur les ailes l isolement
bancaire de la russie est évidemment
fondamental alors évidemment ça des
conséquences sur nous mêmes
on en est ce qu'il faut aller par en
tout cas il faut diminuer notre
consommation de gaz russe alors tout le
monde sait maintenant que la langue
utilisée c'est peu et que l'europe on
utilise beaucoup plus que les allemands
ont peut-être de façon très prématurée
et que nous avions dénoncée à l'époque
d'ailleurs abandonné le nucléaire au
profit du dieu de la de l'énergie
fossile quand même une une décision un
peu un peu baroque dans le monde où on
est aujourd'hui pour des raisons
politiques et pour des raisons
écologiques dont il faut se séparer du
gaz russe au fur et à mesure du temps il
ya beaucoup d'intérêts derrière tout ça
lorsqu'on est la construction de nord
stream 2 qui double le canal de
communication entre la russie
l'allemagne du gaz beaucoup
d'entreprises ont mis beaucoup d'argent
dont des entreprises européennes donc
c'est évidemment déçu j'ai tout à fait
fondamentaux mais il faut se passer du
gaz russe en réalité ces crises la crise
du coc vide comme l'analyse de litres
elle montre qu'on a besoin de plus
d'indépendance sur des sujets
parfaitement stratégique qui évidemment
il ya une mondialisation enfin on en est
à genre humain qui vit sur une seule
planète donc on a évidemment besoin
d'échanger commercialement
intellectuellement mais on a aussi
besoin d'autonomie sur ce qui nous
semble être les les éléments
fondamentaux il ya quand même un
sentiment d'impuissance de la part des
français notamment qui sont devant leur
écran téléviseur on annonce plus de 2000
morts quand marie paule ces derniers
jours
vous nous dites aujourd'hui ça va être
une guerre longue il faut faire le ont
fait le pari des pressions économiques
des sanctions économiques c'est quoi ces
trois mois il ya beaucoup de gens qui
ceux qui sont sur les plateaux télé il
ya beaucoup de commentaires dans tous
les sens
oui oui mais non mais marioupol comme
tous les autres c'est toutes les images
qu'on voit sont des muses images
insupportables chacun se projette avec
sa propre famille et des bandes autour
de soi relevé une température et de fin
à une alimentation qui n'arrive plus
enfin bon c'est absolument insupportable
pour rien pour rien pour rien pour deux
pour rien enfin rien ne justifie ça mais
de toute façon en plus cher à rien juste
pour pour pour la pour le lait goudin
d'un dirigeant qui rêve une ancienne et
sa magie vrai et sa vague et ça va durer
je ne sais pas ce que dante est vladimir
poutine et je pense ne pas être le seul
dans le monde à ne pas savoir ce qu'il a
réellement en tête je ne sais pas la
capacité du peuple russe on l'accepté je
ne connais pas le niveau d'information
du peuple russe dont on dit qu'il est
évidemment extrêmement faible il ya
cette journaliste ou cette femme hier
très extraordinaire qui vous cette
productrice et au journal de télé de 2,2
de russie vient à brandir une pancarte
est bien et il se met dans la gueule du
loup c'est dire que derrière elle sait
qu'elle va être arrêté maltraités enfin
c'est beaucoup de courage toutes ces
périodes là elle montre à la fois ceux
qui ont des nerfs ceux qui n'en n'ont
pas ceux qui ont du courage ceux qui
n'en n'ont pas et c'est en soi en soi un
exemple le peuple ukrainien pour nous je
crois un exemple on a besoin de les
aider on peut pas les aider
militairement je crois que tout le monde
l'a bien compris et je comprends bien
que monsieur élèves qui le demandent
bien sûr et qui ne demanderait pas à sa
place mais on ne peut pas le faire parce
que dans ce cas là ont des cloches un
conflit bien plus grave encore bien plus
génocidaire encore et et des concours
aux comptes ne sera pas arrêté donc on
ne peut pas le faire donc on a besoin la
fois d'une pression militaire bien sûr
d'une organisation militaire n'a besoin
d'une europe qui réagissent de plus en
plus fortement et l'europe elle même je
trouve commence à gagner ses galons dans
cette dans cette affaire le président
macron la lah président
la réunion à versailles a été très
importante les décisions prises par
l'allemagne dans le domaine militaire
sont évidemment très importante et la
cohésion des décisions la cohérence des
décisions prises sur le plan bancaire
que nous sur le plan économique sont aux
sons sont fondamentales notre capacité à
pas laisser nous dicter les choses par
uniquement les états unis est aussi
fondamentale la réalité de l'otan est
importante président est pas tort qu'en
disait que l'otan était quand même
préciser aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on voit bien que c'est de
reconstituer ces blocs soudés de défense
des démocraties on va parler des
conséquences pour le porte monnaie des
français mais d'abord un mois est ce que
les grandes entreprises françaises on
pense notamment à total doivent rester
en russie aujourd'hui je me fasse ses
sims est évidemment compliqué pour des
entreprises d'arrêter tout d'un coup
toute production sa part des
répercussions
cas par cas je ne savais pas si je le
comprends je ne connais pas suffisamment
dans le détail les intérêts de total il
ya des constructions énorme en arctique
y avait il ya beaucoup de choses que
ceux comme ça je peux comprendre qu'on
ne coupe pas immédiatement des relations
cela dit il faut de la clarification il
faut que les sanctions soient est
importante et ses sanctions elles ont un
prix donc si c'est à ce prix là il faut
évidemment
les sanctions elles ont des conséquences
sur l'économie française sur le porte
monnaie aussi des français ce que ce
matin vous dit aux français mais il faut
faire des efforts il faut participer à
l'effort de guerre est ce qu'il faut
accepter de payer une partie du prix de
5 je pense qu'on n'a pas l'on n'a pas
dire aux français que ça il fallait
franchir il s'en rendre compte qu'on
n'est pas des gamins
chacun on voit bien que quelques tout ça
que tout ça est extrêmement reliés et on
voit bien que les sanctions que nous
prenons les gens une répercussion sur
notre propre vie quand on appelle à plus
de modération dans l'utilisation de son
propre chauffage
donc là la chasse anti gaspi ça a été le
cas lors du premier choc et du deuxième
choc pétrolier tout choquent tout choc
énergétique abouti à une modération il
faut supporter aussi une inflation qui
va augmenter
de façon structurellement l'inflation va
augmenter parce qu'on change de monde un
monde plus propre à montrent plus d'être
nécessairement un bon
évidemment des conséquences des
conséquences sur l'alimentation les
productions alimentaires
l'alimentation du bétail l'alimentation
des humains enfin à les angles tous ces
sujets sont évidemment pour in fine et
le pouvoir d'achat alors ça veut dire
qu'on doit être capable à un moment
donné de faire quelques efforts pour je
pense essayer de dire dans quel monde on
a envie de il faut pouvoir d'achat des
français
non enfin la banque de france l'a dit
sur la croissance des économies sur le
pouvoir d'achat c'est très difficile ça
dépend de l'inflation ces cylindres ou
deux je verrai ça dépend aussi des
mesures que le gouvernement peut prendre
le gouvernement l'a prend une très bonne
mesure le moins 15 centimes à la pompe
oui parce que c'est une mesure simple
quand on dit ah mais pourquoi cette
avance et pas avant dans le débat
présidentiel un peu baroque là on sait
pas avant parce qu'ils vont quand même
la mettre en place c'est pas si simple
que ça donc il faut qu'un centime ce
n'est pas rien c'est à peu près le
niveau de la tva puisque seule la tva
est indexé sur le prix les autres taxes
contrairement à ce qu'ont dit les autres
taxés sur le volume donc à la limite
plume prix augmentent moyen de volume
moyen d'entrer fiscal sur cette question
de l'énergie que l'on évoqué à
l'instinct avec total à la france a
quand même fait le pari depuis beaucoup
d'années du nucléaire et le fait que une
guerre pour la première fois se
produisant un pays craint aussi doté en
termes de nucléaire est-ce que ça remet
en cause la stratégie de la france non
je crois pas et ça pose une question
c'est vrai vous avez raison à ces
nouvelles qu'on est probablement
quelques-uns découvert quelques millions
sans doute je ne sais pas que l'ukraine
était autant nucléarisé aidant
tchernobyl était aux portes de l'ukraine
mais je ne savais pas que je ne savais
pas qu'il y avait en tout cas la
l'importation d'une guerre dans un pays
avec des centrales nucléaires pose une
question de sécurité c'est évident
non non non non non parce que il faut
classer nos prières et nos
préoccupations
de demain la france ne pas être envahi
j'espère en tout cas par quiconque il y
en avait quand même des alliances
solides et une défense solide et qui va
être l'être de plus en plus donc on a
besoin de l'énergie nucléaire vous
pouvez pas dire il faut plus d'énergie
fossile et puis vous réfugier sur sur
une non réponse sur les conséquences de
ce de cela il faut ijar chizé les choses
si la hiérarchie en ce qui concerne
l'écologie c'est bien de produire propre
d'avoir de ne pas de ne pas transformer
les climats par des rejets de carbone
alors il faut l'énergie décarbonée c'est
la première des priorités même si
l'énergie nucléaire avait évidemment un
certain nombre de défauts le traitement
des déchets tout le monde le sait bien
mais mes classes on donne aux problèmes
quand on veut résoudre tous les
problèmes ensemble on y ont ni on n'y
arrive pas en tout cas les ukrainiens
font preuve d'une extraordinaire
résistance
résilience on dit maintenant qui force
le respect et qui force l'idée que une
nation quand elle a une identité comme
les cliques rennes a sa propre identité
très lié à l'identité russe évidemment
elle est capable de beaucoup de choses
et je suis très admirative du peu plus
connus on va revenir sur ces 15
centièmes vous dites c'est une très
bonne mesure c'est une mesure qui est
prévu pour quatre mois est ce que pour
vous il faut de la solution plus pérenne
oui à terme c'est évidemment la
modification de notre politique
énergétique de nos consommations
d'énergie c'est plus d'electric de
l'électrique produits de manière propre
nom de façon non fossiles
donc tout ça on le sait bien et tout ça
est en oeuvre il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup
d'améliorations durant ce ce quinquennat
et puis il y en aura encore beaucoup
plus pourquoi parce qu'à une prise de
conscience emmanuel macron et le
président français qui pour maintenant
collectivement et pas uniquement en
france c'est vrai je pense en europe et
dans à peu près partout dans le monde
aujourd'hui même parmi les plus buté sur
le sur le sujet une prise de conscience
qu'on peut pas continuer à faire de la
planète une sorte de poubelles qui qui
qui à un moment donné évidemment se
retournera contre
les hommes et des femmes qui l'habitent
oui oui bah écoutez cccc le sait le
retour de l'augmentation du niveau de
tes a dû à l'augmentation du prix donc
c'est ce retour ce juge de retour donc
ça me semble être assez
la voulait baisser quand vous faites 15
centimes ça revient à baisser en réalité
la tva pendant pendant un certain temps
c'est vous rendez une part de la tva que
vous avez versé donc ça revient à ça ça
ne peut être que conjoncturelles on peut
pas sans arrêt sauter sur sa chaise en
disant faut baisser les taxes et qu'il
arrive quelque chose faut baisser les
impôts c'est vrai la france est trop
imposer donc il faut baisser les impôts
le soutien toute politique dont celle d'
emmanuel macron pour son deuxième mandat
comme il l'a fait d'ailleurs dans lors
de son premier mandat de baisser les
impôts mais derrière les impôts il ya
évidemment le financement d'un certain
nombre de dépenses donc j'ai c'est très
très bien toujours de dire il faut
baisser les albums enfin de l'autre côté
il faut évidemment ce moment là aussi
accepté de baisser les impôts ou des
dépenses et là il ya moins qu'imad
candidat oui mais il a raison il faut
qu'il a fait donc on peut pas il a fait
son effet sur les entreprises pour juger
plus le moment de faire des baseball
poursuivre en même temps que la baisse
des dépenses halal à la réduction de la
vitesse d'accélération des dépenses nos
dépenses elles elles bougent de 1,1 de 1
3% en volume chaque année 1 % à peu près
en moyenne orco in c'est trop il faut
blé baissé d'environ de moitié il faut
que la vitesse d'augmentation de la
dépense elle soit réduite d'où moins de
moitié et en même temps avoir une
croissance suffisant donc à partir des
réformes qu'il faut mener une croissance
suffisante pour absorber une fille née
la dette et pour accroître notre
souveraineté financière
c'est un travail de long terme donc il
faut des mesures de court terme qui
évidemment ne vont pas gêner ou au béret
des mesures de long terme on doit pas à
manger son doublé en herbe si je puis
dire donc il faut des mesures de court
terme pour répondre aux problèmes de
conjoncture qui sont évidemment
extrêmement prudents aujourd'hui et puis
il faut des mesures de long terme pour
assurer aux français une augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat le pouvoir d'achat c'est
la résultante d'une politique économique
c'est la résultante de la qualification
du pays c'est la résultante de notre
capacité à produire des richesses
mesure qui a été annoncé ce matin aux
cadres élections d'emmanuel macron celle
des gènes du pendant 10 des
fonctionnaires c'est un peu plus de 2
milliards d'euros ça va pas tout à fait
dans le sens de la réduction des
dépenses je connais pas le détail de
cette pluralité annoncées par le
gouvernement juppé
voilà valade et
moi je vais je vais leur sujet et
ministre la fonction publique et donc on
avait
considéré que le point à 10,2 ne devait
pas dépasser le niveau de l'inflation
puis sens et les 1% ces deux milliards
c'est ça eric mermoud est à peu près oui
et puis in fine et on avait décidé de
geler le point d'indicé sachant que ce
n'est pas le seul élément de la
rémunération des fonctionnaires il faut
bien le comprendre
parce que le point d'indicé ne bouge pas
que les fonctionnaires ne voit pas
augmenter leur pouvoir d'achat c'est pas
moi il ya d'abord une garantie
individuelle de pouvoir d'achat il ya
l'augmentation ya là la progression des
uns et des autres automatique dans les
grilles de l'organisation de la fonction
publique vous est réservé
enfin je veux dire y est
forte il ya une inflation forte donc
faut tenter d'y répondre les les
fonctionnaires ne peuvent pas être des
oubliés de cela
la vraie question elle est sur la
planète l'organisation de la
rémunération des fonctionnaires plus de
rémunération au mérite et c'est donc ça
c'est
et on doit continuer c'est très
important dans le parisien il dit le
système de rémunération des agents
publics dans son ensemble devait être
revue ça veut dire oui j'ai essayé de le
faire j'imagine que amélie le mouchard a
dû essayer également c'est pas si simple
on voit bien que il peut pas y avoir une
rémunération à la veuve la rémunération
au mérite elle est fondamentale
fondamentale il doit y avoir des
différences de rémunérations entre un
fonctionnaire placé dans la même
situation de fait bien son travail avec
tous les outils comme on le fait dans le
prier de
vérification d'un bon travail par
rapport un travail qui est moins bon
voilà des outils de performance c'est
pas
ça dépend combien qui est un peu de gel
du point d'indicé pourquoi pas mais
c'est pas évidemment l'alpha et l'oméga
de l'évolution et la réforme de la
fonction publique si vous étiez resté
dans l'opposition vous dirais que c'est
une mesure électoraliste
non parce que je jeu d'abord j'ai jamais
employé es trop ces termes là je pense
que c'est mon jardin qu'il est temps que
ce soit une mesure électoraliste
pour une raison assez simple c'est que
l'inflation comme la guerre comme le
reste n'ont pas attendu l'élection
présidentielle
les fonctionnaires le demande depuis
longtemps parce que ce point là disent
ils
dont acte
mais ce n'est pas électoraliste parce
que je crois pas que les gens soient
vous savez je crois pas que les gens
soient achetable je crois pas qu'un
électeur en france c'est plus compliqué
que ça ceux qui croient qu'il est
achetable parce qu'on donne tel ou tel à
telle et telle catégorie telle ou telle
chose non ça marche pas comme ça les
français ils sont responsables ils sont
autonomie votre pour qu'ils veulent il
écoute on dit qu'il ya pas de débat il
ya beaucoup de débats en fait ils
écoutent ce que disent chacun des
candidats et puis à un moment donné ils
choisissent l'autre mesures connues du
programme des manuels macron c'est ce
report progressif de l'âge de départ à
la retraite à 65 ans vous vous
souhaitiez une nouvelle réforme des
retraites est-ce que celle qui se
dessine vous paraît la bonne oui ça me
semble être coural d'abord courage de la
part du président de la république voilà
un truc pas électoraliste si vous perdez
et employés pas du tout même donc ça
déclenche des baous et bien qu emmanuel
macron quand il propose quelque chose
comme candidat ça déclenche des débats
quand les autres candidats proposent
quelque chose se déclenche aucun débat
ça montre quand même une petite
différence je pense de niveau et et
d'impact et puis deuxième point c'est
absolument nécessaire oui enfin
je suis pas sûr que si françois hollande
l'avait fait il aurait déclenché le
moindre débat donc non non je pense ou
est ce que c'est un président solide et
sérieux gg l'âge et le c'est une réforme
en que j'appelle de mes voeux depuis
depuis maintenant longtemps gelé défendu
lorsque alors cette fois ci le président
la république a présenté une réforme qui
était pas compréhensible
bien sûr bien sûr et y aller
progressivement ses 9 ans pour aboutir à
65 ans on peut pas parler de retraite
sans parler d'âge moi je veux bien qu'on
essaye d'éviter toujours le sujet
principal quand on s'occupe de quelque
chose qu'on soit comme ça dans l'est
autour du sujet non il faut être au
coeur du sujet et le moment on
dépendront on a le droit finalement de
partir à la retraite il est fondamental
dans un système par répartition c'est
les actifs qui paye la retraite des
retraités
contrairement au moins ce que croient
les gens ils ont l'impression quand ils
cotisent qui cotisent paient eux-mêmes
non ou cotiser pour payer la retraite
c'est ça le système par répartition donc
il est naturel que les actifs qui ont
déjà beaucoup de charges financières
d'ici d'un moment donné que vous avez le
droit à percevoir votre retraite
puisqu'ils vont vous la payez genou
droit de le dire comme vous augmenter
l'âge comme vous augmenter l'âge de
d'espérance de vie comme ils augmentent
au fur et à mesure même si c'est s'est
ralenti ces dernières années eh bien il
est naturel de faire évoluer le système
de retraite par
le système de répartition est en danger
il n'y a pas d'eau rien de ce dont on
n'y a pas d'autres moyens faute aux
autres moyens on les connaît c'est
augmenter les cotisations etc baisser
les retraites personne ne le veut et
c'est évidemment pas possible et puis
c'est aussi quand même beaucoup d'autres
choses c'est pas uniquement une question
d'âge c'est le regard qu'on a sur la
joue travail c'est aussi simple que cela
souvent à 65 ans on est en pleine forme
enfin souvent pas pas pour tout le monde
mais souvent on est en pleine forme donc
il ya quand même l'idée qu'on doit avoir
de l'ambition dans son travail quel que
soit son travail jusque jusque tard
mécanique
les premiers j'ai été le premier à
introduire la pénibilité dans une
réforme des retraites c'était dans les
années 2000 2010 que le président de la
république parle de pénibilité il va
falloir qu'on l'a défini de façon plus
forte crois qu'il doit y avoir du
médical il ya peut-être d'autres
éléments qu'il faut faire rentrer là
dedans mais évidemment qu'un métier qui
vous use prématurément
eh bien vous devez partir plus tôt et je
crois que emmanuel macron il a bien
l'intention évidemment de continuer
cette politique et puis de l'améliorer
donc comme les carrières longues quand
on dit avec quand vous avez commencé à
travailler tôt on partir à 65 ans n'est
pas du tout pas du tout quand vous avez
commencé à travailler tôt avant grosso
modo 18 ou 19 ans vous avez évidemment
la possibilité aujourd'hui comme vous
l'aurez demain dans la nouvelle réforme
portée par par emmanuel macron vous
aurez la possibilité de partir plus tôt
donc regardons les choses en face et si
on d'éviter de faire des débats
politiques vraiment je commençais les
faire en france pour rien
quasiment un thème des retraites qu'ils
soient indexés automatiquement sur
l'espérance de vie ça éviterait le débat
politique et ça permettra d'avoir un
consensus national là dessus
mais ça n'a rien d'injuste si possible
de la faire avec les français je feins
moi j'ai un infini respect pour les
syndicats je pense que c'est très très
utile pour la cfdt ça va de soi aussi
ils ont montré qu'ils étaient capables
d'être un syndicat extrêmement
responsable mais là on peut moi je suis
pas d'accord comme j'étais pas d'accord
avec la cfdt de 2010 le système par
répartition il est fondamental alors on
doit changer les éléments qu'il organise
doom l'âge de départ à la retraite et
cet âge de départ paris peut être baissé
en fonction de la pénibilité en fonction
également 2 bien sûr du début de
carrière très tôt
donc tout ça tout ça et doit être prise
en compte mais les entreprises doivent
être un acteur d'un sujet de réforme des
retraites car être au travail à 60 ans
c'est pas être au moins 65 ans et pas
être au travail à 40 ans et l'évolution
du travail est fondamental lacauve il a
fait changer le travail probablement
durablement la réforme de retraites doit
faire changer le regard de la société
sur l'âge au travail sur la capacité à
se projeter sur aussi la capacité à
améliorer la meilleure des pénibilités
c'est la pénibilité qui est évité
lorsque vous apporter les charges
lourdes lorsque vous êtes exposés au
froid intense lorsque sont des éléments
pénibilité physique extrêmement lourd et
bien les entreprises doivent s'organiser
et investir pour éviter c'est cette
usure prématurée de leur sel à leurs
salariés et c'est une bonne nouvelle on
la réforme des retraites une des rares
réformes de structure qui porte une
bonne nouvelle en elle-même en a bien
qui vous vivez plus longtemps et ben se
tend de plus que vous passez sur une
planète de plus en plus propre je
l'espère plus en plus écologique avec ce
temps là il est divisée en une partie
plus plus de temps au travail et de
l'autre plus de temps là on a bien
compris que le présent dans le public
pouvait compter sur vous pour cette pour
cette réforme jeudi le président sortant
vous pourriez la porte
mais je sais rien je ne suis pas de je
suis pas candidat avoue n'est pas grave
non enfin jeunes non non non non enfin
je
sais pas si c'est pas un sujet pour moi
c'est pas insulter pas si emmanuel
macron présente jeudi son programme il
parlera des retraites notamment il ya
d'autres mesures dont vous avez
connaissance et
évidemment discuté à l'intérieur de
l'équipe de campagne avec lui même mais
mais il le présentera jeudi donc il
reste peu de temps peu de temps attendre
il ya quelque chose que vous lui avez
demandé vous moi j'ai proposé un certain
nombre de choses oui j'ai parlé par
exemple des retraites je pourrais
d'autres choses et comment j'ai comme
quoi
l'occasion d'évoquer le sujet du modèle
social évidemment qui pose des questions
avec plein de gens qui sont oubliés
des droits et des devoirs
autour du retour du retour à l'équipe
avec l équilibre des finances plongé la
question dans le par exemple dans 10
février quand vous annoncez votre
soutien à emmanuel macron vous avez dit
je prends le pari qu emmanuel macron et
sincèrement réformateurs et qu'il sera
utilisé la liberté de ce second mandat
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'ils fassent des réformes qui peuvent
être dures voire impopulaires pour vous
et lesquels il faut pas faire des
réformes dures parce qu'elles sont durs
oui vous avez pas là pour emmerder
après un homme une femme politique enfin
un homme d'état comme on dit une femme
d'état c'est quelqu'un qui n'est pas
qu'ils ne suis pas l'opinion publique
nécessairement peuple à suivre
heureusement ce n'est que dans l'idée de
ne pas tout toujours la suivent mais qui
ne fuit pas nécessairement l'opinion
publique lorsque l'intérêt général est
en cause qui devance l'opinion publique
il faut faire ce qu'on doit faire
les générations qui viennent j'ai dit
que ce qui m'intéressait c'était quand
même la france de mes propres aux
enfants de mes enfants je me projette en
avant parce qu'il ya de l'enthousiasmé
j'aime bien le mot de bienveillance qu'a
prononcé le président hier c'est assez
nouveau dans le débat politique donc
tout ça ça me va bien il ya un regard
optimiste sur l'évolution de la france
on n'a pas un regard reclus passéiste
frileux peureux moi je suis je suis
j'aime la france souveraine j'aime pas
le souverainisme en tant que mouvement
politique parce que c'est un mouvement
de peur est la peur les très mauvaise
conseillère
j'imagine que vous gardez qu'un bon oeil
bienveillant sur la campagne de valérie
pécresse votre ancienne coéquipière pas
de regrets d'avoir quitté votre famille
politique non d'abord j'ai pas quitter
ma famille politique j'y suis c'est pas
parce qu'on a une carte ou pas une carte
gelés pendant quarante ans j'ai aucune
leçon à apprendre de fidélité loyauté
politique mois et leur a dérivé comme ça
au fur et à mesure j'ai tenté d'éviter
cette dérive c'est pour ça que valérie
pécresse est parti de l air elle n'est
revenue que pour défendre sa propre
candidature elle-même donc changé j'ai
essayé de l'éviter j'ai su l'éviter en
interne bon je je je je pense qu'elle a
besoin d'être plus européen enfin ce jeu
l'ump d'un moment on la porte est très
fort il va un équilibre des choses c'est
plus le cas chez les républicains je
suis je suis un militant je suis de
droite mais je ne crois pas à
l'aveuglément et je pense qu'il faut
beaucoup de lucidité emmanuel macron en
fait un peu explosé les lignes c'est pas
un président socialiste non parce que
vous passez pas de l air aux socialistes
on peut très bien considéré qu emmanuel
macron fait la synthèse entre ce qui est
bon entre su de tout ce qui est bon pour
la france merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]